NARRATOR:
Heading back to shore,
the team review the footage
from cameras mounted
on the bait lines.
MEGAN: Chh chh chh chh chh.
Oh, that's such a good one!
HEATHER: So that's when the buoy
went down. You on to that, Meg?
GREG: Look at that.
MEGAN: Oh, it really wanted
that thing. This is awesome.
GREG: Oh, it tears it up.
NARRATOR:
With no claspers visible,
the shark is a juvenile female
and new to the Atlantic
white shark database.
MEGAN: I think we put
this one at like nine. Right?
HEATHER: I've, yeah,
I think so, too.
MEGAN: A nine or ten-footer,
so not a super big one,
still a big shark, but not
really big for a white shark.
GREG: You think this is
typical size
you guys are seeing up here?
HEATHER: It seems to be
a lot of the juveniles,
a lot of the acoustic detections
we get, it's, it's in that,
you know, let's say
9 to 12-foot range.
It's, it's the smaller guys.
GREG: Yeah.
NARRATOR:
It's an important clue
and different to the pattern
Greg and Megan see
some 260 miles to the south
around Cape Cod.
GREG: We do see juveniles,
but a lot of our resident sharks
are big males.
And those big males may be
schoolyard bullies, you know,
pushing these smaller animals
into other parts of their range,
which include, in the summer
and the fall, Canadian waters.
NARRATOR: In 2019, a drone
operator captured sharks
clashing off Cape Cod.
Could territorial adult males
be pushing smaller
white sharks north?
GREG: We also know there are
social interactions
between these sharks
because we see scars.
You know, there are bites,
there are injuries
that are clearly
from other sharks.
And is that associated
with mating?
Certainly it could be.
But it, on juveniles,
it could also be associated
with negative interactions
between sharks.
In other words,
"Get the hell out of here.
This is my neighborhood."
♪
NARRATOR: Territory may
just be part of the puzzle
of what's drawing sharks north.
Canada's Atlantic waters
have some of the richest
fishing grounds in the world.
Sharks in the eight to
nine-feet range are youngsters
and, for the most part,
fish-hunters.
The shape of the seabed here,
combined with the cold
Labrador Current
as it mixes with
the Gulf Stream,
brings nutrients
up to the surface.
(birds squawking)
It makes for the perfect
conditions for marine life
to flourish
in spectacular numbers.
♪
Canada is also experiencing
one of its hottest
Augusts on record.
Could the mix of so much food
and warming waters
be part of what draws
white sharks north?